but we begin with that breaking news
from Ukraine a helicopter has crashed
killing at least 18 people including a
number of top level officials
we have the latest images from the scene
showing the burning wreckage of that
helicopter crash of police officer from
the local police service said the
helicopter crashed in a town near the
capital of Kiev Ravari is around 50
miles from the center of Kiev the
helicopter crashed near a nursery and a
residential building local official said
that at the time children and staff were
in the nursery but confirmed everyone
has now been evacuated from the scene
Deborah is on the phone for us um
Deborah what more do we know
so we know that um Ukraine's interior
Minister was on that helicopter and was
killed in the crash his Deputy was also
killed and a number of other officials
it's a it's a truly shocking development
um I I think it's the first time since
the full scale Invasion that you've got
a a top government Minister killed we
obviously we don't know the cause of
that helicopter crash uh whether it um
was an accidental or whether it had been
um brought down as some result of of the
of the war the fact that it was around
the key area
um rather than closer to the actual
active front lines
um with obviously a factor in terms of
trying to working out what actually
happened but
um absolutely shocking we're seeing lots
of um tributes on social media already
from
colleagues of the Interior Minister he's
someone who was incredibly active going
to the sites the most dangerous places
of the country
um I've met him a couple of times on my
trips to Ukraine
um once in butcher that
um town outside key where you'll
remember those horrendous atrocities
were committed by Russian forces in the
early weeks of the war and then I also
met him in harkiv region when he was
visiting one of the cities that
Ukrainian forces liberated in their
counter-offensive in the Autumn a sign
of how this is a minister not sitting
behind his desk but a man who it was
absolutely around the country
um actively involved in his country's
efforts to fight Russia's invasion
okay looking at the um the crash scene
um
we know that youngsters were in a
nursery with their teachers at the time
residential area as well
um are we the latest we're hearing that
people on the ground are safe
um well I I imagine it it sounds like it
was a helicopter to crash I mean
horrendous for
um the the children and the teachers at
that Nursery it's interesting since the
um the Russians were pushed back from
around Keith
um a semblance of life has restarted
with children going back to school it's
hard to imagine given that there is
still the missile threats
um that they're able to go back back to
school but they're trying desperately to
get on with life
um but absolutely terrifying it's hard
to imagine the idea of a helicopter just
plunging down in the way that this has
happened but
um a really significant moment as well
was the loss of this senior minister
and and these ministers traveling around
as you said you've seen him in varying
parts of the country previously on your
visits to Ukraine
um it must be incredibly dangerous to
travel by helicopter
well exactly it's obviously it's the
fastest way to move around the country
Ukraine is fast
um and The Minister's time will be
precious but yes each time they travel
by helicopters by car
um they are putting their lives at risk
and
um you know these are these aren't
military people these are civilians and
civilian jobs that obviously have now
got uh military roles given that the
country is at War and martial law is in
place
um but it really underlines and uh
brings to home the huge risk that this
the entire government is taking is they
lead their country in this war
what sort of
damage to the morale of the Ukrainian
people do you think that these deaths
will have
that's a really good question
um because like I said I don't I don't I
think it is the first time that a senior
top government Minister has died and
again we don't know the reason for it it
could just be a an unfortunate accident
but clearly he would have been moving
around on that trip uh you assume
um because of some reason to do with uh
responding to the war whether he was
going to decide if
um you know a potential war crimes he
was very active in in that in in terms
of
um leading the efforts to gather
evidence of of war crimes suspected war
crimes by
um Russian forces when he was going to
these places I remember when I met him
in um in butcher he was visiting the
site where there were a number of
charred bodies
um uh by a car that uh had been killed
by Russian forces and so in terms of the
damage to morale of people have of
course it's going to be a huge blow when
um you know a senior official dies in
this way
um but equally this country has lost so
many uh good people so many
um of their young on the front line
fighting in this war so many civilians
killed by these missile attacks
um and artillery attacks by the Russian
forces and so as well as
impacting morale I imagine as well it
would it would also
um just strengthen resolve to continue
resisting
okay so for people just tuning our way
can you um update us on what we do know
about what's happened please Deborah
um so we know that a helicopter has
crashed
um in an eastern district
um in Keith it is The Bravery District
where this helicopter came down it
um was carrying the uh the interior
Minister uh the deputy interior Minister
um and a number of other officials uh on
the ground that these two children sadly
were killed this helicopter landed close
to a nursery
um and you know you can imagine
investigators on the scene now trying to
work out exactly what happens and what
brought that helicopter down
indeed so
um the latest death toll we're hearing
is 18 people aboard that um helicopter
when it crashed we'll get more
information including the interior
Minister and his Deputy Deborah for now
thank you